as soon as we went to break riki walk in
so we've been having a [ __ ] blast
talking yeah already begun before
Christ's killing well he'd love to show
the killing and I said the original
version or the American went American
like that like there isn't like denying
there was another version of course yeah
I never denied it I said I just didn't
see it or do research I'm sadist by shut
up
don't [ __ ] just jump in American
exceptionalism you think that we've
started everything that's really ugly
view all the office from Carroll to
[Laughter]
welcome Ricky Gervais what we're talking
about today what's what's the world
outrage that what what are we doing
what's going on I feel like everybody's
still kind of hungover from Michael
Jackson in our Kelly week yeah we say
this there was a new IQ tally BBJ
allegedly been found on some guy had
like a tape of vh1 sports moments or
something and there was like Mark Kelly
he said it was having sex with an
underage person on he just turned it
over to prosecutors in Pennsylvania Oh
snick I want to know why I was watching
vh1 not in this prison
you don't even snitch on yourself yeah
it was some guy he had a tape and I
guess he got from a friend and he said
are Kelly is like it was like one of
those ones they probably put stuff right
they taped over and taped over and it
wasn't labeled and then all of a sudden
they put it in the VCR and there's a
scene with our Kelly pissing on another
is that what it was
I say that i'm assuming yes which sounds
like gloria allred has taken up the case
get out of here that's right she tries
to stay off camera usually but this time
she's jumping on camera r kelly he's
just he has finished he he has made such
a stir talking about Kelly it was it
wasn't he finished anyways he should
have been yeah but people kept working
whatever I mean apart from that that but
why are we still even talking even if he
hadn't done all that we wouldn't be is
not he's not around is he's not really
and he's not he still does get did
Kancil he had one booked in Germany they
had to move to a bigger venue this is
after the documentary yeah and then they
moved to a bigger venue but then I guess
another allegation came out and then
they finally just went original you're
talking about the American or Kelly not
yeah I'm talking about the IDS the
singer not the fat one yeah yes it's on
Netflix now well six yeah yeah but
that's because it's the days of Twitter
so I don't know what it would have been
like well the reaction is good or as mad
it's it's insane but I think that's a
reflection of the fact that it they just
send an email and 140 million people get
it in there involved I mean it's just
the model of Netflix is crazy it really
is like it and it's just like oh there's
a new Ricky Gervais sting I don't know
what this is but I have it yeah I just
watch it it's about you it's like going
to Google you can't you can't not see
Google once a day right it's like that
right I'll look for the first yeah so
it's been great
Oh cheers thank you very much and it's
about to say it's about a guy named Tony
whose wife has passed away and you're
pretty suicide I don't know how much
ever you want to give away but you see
it's the ground running so yeah you see
a video of her saying if you're and
she's obviously going through
chemotherapy and said if you'll and she
knows it's terminal she says if you're
watching this I'm not around anymore
sounds funny so far right face embarrass
was in our lovely you are and then she
leaves a guide for life and it's really
sort of mundane like take the bins out
on a Tuesday and all that and then you
see that he's depressed means he's gonna
kill himself at the dogs hungry and he
lives long enough to say right okay I'm
gonna carry on for a while but I'm gonna
say and do exactly what I want I'm gonna
he tries to become a psychopath so it
doesn't hurt him anymore
and he and it's one last adventure at
saying what he
once and then he can always kill himself
he treats it like a superpower and
that's and that's the setup that's the
concept and it really is really
hilarious you call a kid a fat ginger
[ __ ] that made me laugh out loud yes I
say I'm not a pedo and if I was you'd be
safe you tell me that will change it
because I just look I love that see
cause like it's this scene where you're
walking past a school and some kid says
pedo you don't think it's gonna be like
Oh walkie sitcom thing yeah I'm not a
pedo and all the kids start and instead
you just call me tubby ginger [ __ ]
there's lots of that but obviously it
develops it's not it's not just me going
and saying [ __ ]
you just came up with a with a creative
hook of a show so you could call kids
can't see and that's really what the
show is for like 14 months to say the
c-word imagine if that was my motivation
yeah all that effort just to say that
yes the kid there when you shot that
that reversal or no no he wasn't no I
see that I went I went I have a hubba
hubba hubba and everyone laughed of
course but and there but I think the I
think the kids seen it and his mum
defended it on twit when they saw its
cause any other loveliest day he wasn't
even there you know again fake outrage
oh they were outraged about that of
course well then but you know a few of
them were it's like it's like half a
dozen people and then a paper picks it
up and says so-and-so said a thing and
people are outraged you know naught
point naught naught naught 1 percent of
people are outraged the rest of us
couldn't give a [ __ ] and we wouldn't
even know about it if you hadn't found
two tweets and put it in your paper
headline it's just it just gets in the
way it's nonsense
it is nonsense yeah the fact that you're
as high-profile as you are and you still
say the stuff you say and you still
defend it the way you do it yeah it's
really great I'm asking for it all right
no but it's funny it's it's like you
just matter in the end at the end but I
think I think this is why things don't
get on telly because people try and do
something quite brave anyway and then
they get scared or the broadcaster that
we get complaints right isn't doing the
morality of the piece it's that do we
have to write letters right okay [ __ ]
that and also most people can take it
and so what if they do complain who
gives a [ __ ] either
in there right I've never had a
complaint upheld times the complaint
will be false
Steve Wales the office doesn't have to
worry about [ __ ] sponsors and
boycotting them no can running out there
even tweeting swearing and they were
getting stick for people saying this is
an official tweet how dare you swear
they don't care that my children follows
this do though be careful what your
children at the end it's your
responsibility we've got to look out for
your children no no no Trump she said
[ __ ] during a [ __ ] speech in the
things he's done that's that that's
10,000 words did you know it's like
outrage culture it's what you realize it
doesn't do anything it doesn't matter
you can ignore it you don't you don't
get outraged by the outrage anymore in
fact you're less than it did say three
years ago yeah oh god much less much
less well I went through a thing of
thinking this is unfair they've ruined
it right that's not true they've lied
they've ruined it then you realize they
doesn't matter didn't make a difference
for any one's reading their newspaper
but you know most people have got more
Twitter followers than new people people
read newspapers oh yeah then you embrace
it and and monetize it like I tell
trolls their their tweet made me quote
of a million because it was three
minutes of a show that I tell them and
then you're over it and you don't look
like you shouldn't look either way you
shouldn't praise that you shouldn't
invite you should ignore it and it
almost becomes good for branding when
the outrage starts to come in it's like
good this is what we were waiting I say
you have to do you have to actually do
something bad illegal to in public to be
in trouble when he says in trouble for
saying a thing that puts ticket sales up
so at least he said a thing so write me
is don't [ __ ] say anything
no-one's ever not come to see a comedian
because well he's used as offensive
language right
yeah never heard ticket sales I was in
Vegas and I follow every go I follow I
follow [ __ ] Ron Jeremy he went on
stage he's doing comedy now unwatchable
he would have been better off just
pulling his dick out and waving yeah
anyhow I said a joke about him after he
got off there was a porn star in the
audience I offended a point she was
backstage complaining about my joke
well [ __ ] triple anal was mad at
something when John Wayne was canceled
40 years after his death and you're
going I couldn't believe in the 70s when
John Wayne was old he was a racist John
Wayne the guy in the cowboy hat what you
know but it wasn't like they unearthed
it it was it went out he said it four
years ago right it was out it's been
there forever publish publish but the
main thing is what are we to do about it
right dad's they want to go to these
people right you've won he died you've
got your way right the worst punishment
for a racist is to die well done you've
won he's no longer around they want to
change the name of the airport that's
why that's what it all came up does John
Wayne Airport is it is that Burbank I'm
not sure but the I did John Wayne
Airport I saw that we have that as well
we have outrage are you at it here with
taking down the Confederate statues and
I think that you should just tell the
truth so leave up the statue and say
great general bit racist event of the
fork kiddy Fiddler's right put it on the
statute rather semicolon is like an
asterisk like a Hall of Fame almost good
cars anti-semitic yeah so ron jeremy was
not going on stage I like Ron have you
met Ron before did you have any
experiences with him he [ __ ] her girl
while she put my penis in her mouth you
see
okay so yeah okay
did you know but no no you know what
I shouldn't yeah but you want you know
no that happened you want a picture no I
just being it happened within one side
and ron jeremy within the other side and
this is a normal job right and you went
to work in exactly the summer go good
weekend
yeah um you know one Jeremy I don't know
well yeah is a little fat guy and if I
do a while she what was it she put my
penis in our job this is our place yes
yeah they would love that story in an
officer no I think the definite you get
hard looking at Ron at the same time
well it was difficult it was more the
situation I'm I'm ready shocked you
don't think that you could get hard in
that situation fat bookends ruined it
let's talk about something else
oh you mean this is like you know if
it's tough if you have like a chronic
hero and you have to perform with that
this is gender mind here in the stories
right that's left up to my imagination
but I don't want to be there Oh in all
honesty the fact that I'm looking down
like that is uncomfortable I'm not
looking like clenching his teeth the
real Jim now the original do you call do
you ever call you daddy or anything like
that encouraging part I don't know maybe
she did I don't know whatever I've said
because look her like in with the
clenching of the teeth it's like when we
do maybe have 2004 yeah no I don't think
she called me daddy
okay no okay so that answers the
question Ricky but it's like it's like
you talk about it like it really is
it's like Coppola talking about do you
remember filming there yeah I'm if it
was a summer day and I think I think
[Laughter]
you've both done' you've done a lot of
great work jim has memories about both
mine was just that filmed I mean yeah
it's like filming it's like it's like a
diary of a serial killer one of those
people in the outsider art that fair
that filmed every [ __ ] they ever and now
it's a [ __ ] book right in an art
gallery what were you eating here for
the show
so apart from I was watching after life
I had a question about it go on it felt
like obviously this is something that
you've thought about so there's two
things here one was the first thought I
go I wonder if Ricky is more afraid of
Jane dying were you dying like first
thing oh oh maybe he's not right now
face so I want to go first you do that's
a dress you don't want to deal with no I
want to go first
what you want you to and then there's a
line there and says about she'd rather
live missing her husband than have him
live you know missing her that's a
lovely thing but I think most of us are
selfish in that we want to go first
right and not have to deal with ever in
real life yeah you want to live outlive
your wife dear yeah you're not an MRI
but I'll be 62 and June 11 26 and 28
miles getting married in May right okay
who's your favorite you want to die
first
wait who's my favorite kid yeah I love
all my kids to death
more okay I love them all but you sure
you just want the same time and I'm
still there to deal with that pain three
times in a row let's just knock it out
at once yeah oh my god play golf I wanna
get an RV and take off without anybody
know I love my you know I guess we girls
this show you're paid to entertain
people
yeah and we fail that's what we come up
with well done and your wife where where
do you want her to go in the mix you
wanted to live long enough to look after
them and then go just before you I my
wife yeah listen we're good friend now
you don't want to see a good friend go
now I don't want to a buddy and she's
basically writes all the stuff she's
like my showrunner uh you know I can see
what's real style it was what others say
no not my standup no she should but
you'd like for her to would you like for
your wife to die before the kids are
after the kids obviously your no no
because I don't want her to die before
cuz I don't want to take care of my kids
[Laughter]
21 by Bonnie you know then but I don't I
don't I don't
that's Rich's website this is why we
love it God did you see here that Sam it
says corner comedy club Falls Canada and
he put attentive attentive yeah he meant
to put tentative
but I didn't know that I'm not really
big on spelling no no or subtitles you
only watch the American version of great
great drama from around the world but
you have to read as well first of all
[Laughter]
when you're going on tour you're trying
to figure everything out do you usually
list the dates while they're still
tentative so we get so distracted by the
fact that he doesn't know the difference
between attentive and tentative why
would you list the tentative dance on
your website just in case okay that's a
good point once it's confirmed they're
ready to buy the island
why isn't it even confirmed yet it is
confirming we didn't buy that you put
attentive it I got bigger things to
worry about doing my [ __ ] dumb
website
that's going to my website going you can
stop right there I do enjoy that because
it's really just the Google calendars on
the website there's a print option that
is she wants to pick out it was created
by geo cities so the main page that is
like do you have a lot of say an invoice
when you get one of those things picture
yeah yeah nobody made it is a template
that comes dad
and that's great so do you have fans
that maybe come up and they'll print out
the calendar and have you sign it
that's the difference I have fans okay
yes yes they come on like when you're at
a wrestling gig yeah that's all I got
pictures a picture of us at the bottom
right that's nice your little picture
section bottom right
that's a nice me and day that's all old
picture oh this is not early my spice I
[Laughter]
wish it was recent do you do do what do
you do do you just do constantly tour do
you do specials like what I did it
special we'll try it it's so [ __ ]
cool I did it at a 12-step convention
because I have you know 33 or sober so
and never had to yeah yeah yeah he was
just hoping to get a little credit for
to mention the numbers I'm listening
that need hear a message okay because
you don't carry one so what well you
don't have to get high if you want to
stop I was a [ __ ] full blown crack
addict and I stopped crack really yeah
Jesus so if he's not that this is now
this is real what so what yeah what year
was this don't know three years ago two
years ago from 2000 into equations now
three so so you always I was 28 question
that's every audience says this
so so so when you were comedian yes I
had maybe two or three years and my last
night I knew what's gonna rehab I call
this guy that books one-nighters you
know but I don't know how it started how
you've been you've been drinking or
doing drugs from earlier than yeah I
started when I was like 15 year 15 yes
we're born where'd you come from in
Jersey so your Jersey even bad you know
what you a bad neighborhood yeah yeah
yeah divorced family do my everything as
a kid for attention it was always
negative because she you know I said
from a divorced family you feel you not
getting the attention you deserve
negative attention is better than none
yeah obviously
yeah more and more so yes so you fall in
Chuck you you fall into the crowd where
you feel a little better than you at
school what do you drop out of school I
was in English class one day and I said
can I go to the bathroom and I got the
hall pass and I never came back that was
third shot I was getting high right okay
and I started I had a big business
remodeling houses I mean I when I was 20
or 21 I had seven eight guys working for
me
remodeling houses but so what it was
interfering then you were just getting
high you know no energy we wanted hope
then I was doing not I was I want to
smoke in it but once it has to follow me
you would still work it work working yes
okay
but I would get my guys I would set them
up on the job I go okay this what you
got to do and then I will go to the park
and lay in the Sun because I was too
[ __ ] up from the night before from
partying Hardy and you know a lot of
people do that for your drink you know I
you know I am I drink every night but it
but I don't let it interfere with my day
and you know in the next day so but but
so what was that then that was that was
that was drink cocaine yeah you know
progress what we have started we yeah up
or partying whatever concert and game it
and then and was the cocaine to so you
could stay up longer drinking and
smoking as opposed to it you loved
failing it was just I just like color it
was glad it was fun but the freebase see
the coke the freebase income - I I
started commerce don't commonly two
years yeah I don't know who or what but
then I ended up with a couple comics
that also free based you know did crack
or freebase and this is a years or two
or three years I mean we took a major
star one time you know we were doing a
gig he's a major star now we were 20 gig
and he we had to drop him off you know
and we said hold on we got to go make a
stop first so I went up to Harlem and
bought freebase or crack and he was a
wreck you know he was just some little
waked and then we went to the Lower East
Side in the other comic bought heroin so
the other comics in the backseat
shooting up and in the kids like [ __ ]
get me the [ __ ] out of here
[Laughter]
and then I I knew I was gonna die or
right so tell me so tell me when you
take a what a hit of crack it's a little
wrong when you burn it and your stuff
you take it down you smoke it and then
and then what how long and that's the
best video you wanna [ __ ] suck a dick
or rob somebody for more I mean you
can't stop the crack is like so isn't it
like 90% addictive on the first hit or
something
well it's coke is not physically
addictive no coke but addiction
besides you know heroin Barbra George
yeah is is it's the obsession and
compulsion well I've heard that that the
street some true Street heroin is is
like less than four
so it's not physiologically addictive
but it's the paraphernalia and yet they
even placebo some heroin addicts and it
worked it did Wow yeah yeah yeah but
does it help with the physical
withdrawal if I get so you get a placebo
and you don't uh and you physically
withdrawal you don't do it doesn't help
probably there's probably things
happening you know your there's bit so
you shut down doesn't it like you know
you can only eat sugar because your
stomach's quick I mean this per there's
probably things and also not everyone
takes the city week some of them just go
bang um I wanna in my neck now so I mean
that's the you never tried any drug I've
never oh yeah but I've never - I've
never [ __ ] done that sources well show
show anyhow so once you you know I my
last night I called this guy go look I'm
gonna rehab tomorrow
give me a gig so I got you know $60 then
for one-nighter I went to New York what
four vials pack of cigarettes smoke till
sunup my mother drove me to rehab and I
never picked up since that's amazing
that you actually knew that and then
went through with it like this at one
time when you're high you know you
beforehand you want to do it then you
get high and you're like [ __ ] that I'm
not going but the fact that you actually
went well I knew I was going I just
wanted one list I did that one time I
smoked in ate two coke and I went up to
this rehab and I had no idea I just I go
I got to go into rehab and then by the
time they started to go do you have
insurance I go no no and I came down
already so I left but it was like got
only like five guys you go in high you
go in high is that all you try to get
your last high in goodbye it's not how
did you know you were gonna die like
what made you to go like I'm definitely
gonna die you're a good ending to not
give up or you doc right that's true of
anything but it's you're gonna die too
soon either you're gonna go to jail and
not how I was how much were you doing
it's my I mean I didn't have money then
I did as much as I could get whenever I
could get money when you go to jail if
you know no but is that is that worse
because it isn't a rehab type thing and
you can still get it or is it what
I thought I would imagine making good I
mean that's one of my worst fears going
to jail
I've never yeah that and why not in
listening it in a war I know I'm Way too
old for that now yeah I was relaxed very
would offer that no one's gonna
conscripted gel is it the sexual assault
of the beatings or the things that are
rumored to happen in jail everything
yeah I die I'm getting a little bit
stir-crazy in this room yeah so yeah a
little bit you taking away that's the
worst that even unless it was like I
won't people say oh you're going to
solitary confinement okay walk it but I
could do a couple of weeks in solitary
confinement but to be in there with
people like you know rich right for like
a year it would be to you don't you want
to hear the story of Jim and another and
ron jeremy with that one jeremy with my
cellmate yeah have you ever gone to jail
walk through Alcatraz me I know make
anyone to that's almost surreal it's a
romantic sized version now of what agile
is a tourist version yeah jail
but it's like that clean dry white thing
is almost worse because it's just people
in clean lovely stainless steel cages
it's weird it's like battery farming
what you not I mean it's almost I almost
like the idea more of like The Count of
Monte Cristo you know in in a sound a
little learning defense yeah yeah suit
you can be incanting went to San Quentin
but we didn't get to walk through the
cell where the prisoners workers it was
a chickenpox outbreak so they weren't
letting people walk in but you can
actually dig in a posh restaurant Johnny
I'll be the five-star restaurant
somebody into Louden are you kidding me
so when you poke so loud I want to put a
[ __ ] ice pick in her neck
with the ears yeah it kills me to hear
to pop so that's in the show that's all
right okay so well that's right
last time when I flew back from New York
yeah there was a guy sitting next to me
so it's first-class ba right in this
next seat across the aisle all right
there's a guy he's about my age probably
and he's reading the paper and he's
going you know I just sort of looked
like that
and there goes yeah nah and I think by
amongst wife Norton make sure is not
right and I made the judgment no is just
enjoying [ __ ] yawning people looking
around and I'm sort of shrugging like
it's not me and then the fact the 15th
time he went oh excuse me mate can you
do the yawn without all the noises at
the end you say that and then I thought
[ __ ] I'm sat next week for seven hours
cept I just I just had to ask because I
it was driving me mad like insane like
you know when people think and I had to
and I had to kill I felt like that right
we were in a restaurant in San Francisco
beautiful restaurant right me and Jane
and we went early it was like we've you
know jet lag so we were eating at about
half 11 there was no one there we were
looking out over the bay and there was
[ __ ] seals and pelicans and then the
way a war parsley went right and every
time okay now but and Jane I was going
to know if you can't do anything right
you were kind of so every so now I could
hear him going and I was to myself I was
just going so the scenes that are in
this show after life it's just you you
just right that's what the show with
that friend eating across the edge it's
you you're in a restaurant somebody's in
the next table blown their nose I want
to [ __ ] Club them together at least
it was a bloke on the plane doing that
he went he was going to sniffing and I
went over said made you want a tissue
and you're like thank you
wash will say is why I love Voss because
Voss will will say the things that are
not polite like we've been in delis and
the guy will grab his cup to hand it to
them and possibly could you not put your
fingers in my cup
it makes the guy get him a new person
but why doesn't that you shouldn't put
your [ __ ] yes I told him I wasn't
good on this my [ __ ] and there's a lady
in flight this happened so it and this
lady in front of me
she gets her [ __ ] food and now and
her and her coffee her time's up she's
on my time I swear to god she's talking
to the lady behind me I know I went to I
went hey lady I saw Godwin wrap it up
let's go you're done because she was not
six foot five and male your eyes like
you're [ __ ] I'm pretending I'm
looking up okay stop retirement back to
jail I did a show in the jail right it
was a county jail but it was [ __ ]
like but behind me was a dish of potato
chips of bags that we they were staring
at him like that just a bag of potatoes
yeah well there was a village it was a
privilege yeah
and there were so you know and why would
they hide you they were we had some ice
[Laughter]
behind me a shiner said freedom is right
that's just a can of soda this kid was
cleaning up after and he goes can I have
the camera like anything for granted
oh you had a rider is that was your was
that your riders what in canis no no no
Adam so listen and alright but I'm just
saying we take everything for granted in
life sure and you're in jail
oh I can don't kill you for a bag of
[ __ ] chips yeah you know what I mean
and and whatever did you get the chips
away the prisoners do anything that's
not saying can I feed them [ __ ] one
guy goes I'll kill you I just sat in
normal yeah yeah it wasn't a prison it
was a Konami
oh yeah before any prison it's not like
Conair there weren't sort of cannibals
really I mean you know it's a county
they haven't gotten a court you know
people don't people who went in for
fraud could kill you can make so there
they're actually good crowds aren't they
well they're decent popular is happy is
there so probably friends payment yeah
you go up three miles outside London
they're really great that's great if I
can like you see person how [ __ ]
scared is but then solitary confinement
20 23 hours a day in a room where you
can't talk to any of you crazy things
but yeah I would I think you do have
those Count of Monte Cristo
fantasies where you think that you're
gonna just become really great at
something are you gonna use that time to
yourself I think I would fear if I was
in for some reason if I was in a prison
that we're scary people I think I would
like to be locked in my cell Jane right
I concern
cope with loneliness more than at least
that's pretty afraid yeah I mean me
people they're like okay yeah like
talking to this guy like talk to that
guy I play chess man I don't know you
see I've got no idea what the truth is I
think I think all my information comes
from movies and [ __ ] TV it should be
you'd go to jail and the first day there
you'd be in the in the cafeteria or
whatever and you'd be yelling at
somebody for chewing loudly wouldn't I
go up to mr. big and say you've got a
million dollars coming to you if you
kill anyone that comes near me right up
to him and I go you've got a million
dollars coming right this time
if you kill any [ __ ] who comes
near me any we take care of you but you
know what you they would go up to you
and say yeah they they would know who
you know if you got money yeah
and they would protect you or you know
it wouldn't be that bad for me though it
might make a very big friend yeah not if
you were paying him yeah if you don't
sexually assault me I'll give you a
whole bunch of money okay yeah well I
thought that I thought that confused me
I saw a thing there's a guy called Ross
Kemp who was an actor we sort of used
him in extras once and now he does he
goes to the worst gangs in the world he
goes to the worst prisons in the world
and he was in a prison in South Africa
and he was talking to this guy who he
rapes people for their initially rapes
him for fun in jail or his happiness is
the pity's a big guy and he rightfully
right the guys are over the ropes away
and Ross Kemp says to him oh you're gay
he went no okay it was offended I just
know I just raped them he doesn't kick
me he was saying he was basically saying
I'm top dog that's how yeah that's how
dominant I am just a power dynamic
there's nothing sexual dog to show I
have to show them who's boss and then
they go but do you come Oh God
I mean it's just light enough the orgy
come they create an erection with that
position
my worst fear and Jim's best fantasy
well we all depend on the man who was a
large twink I would take it as
preference a preference I mean that'd be
my advice
I'm glad sometimes I don't understand
what Jim's talking about I'm actually
proud of that you know when you don't
you know a girl band or a boy band you
go oh no I didn't I I'd never heard of
them you realize I'm a better person
than I thought now you talk the thing
about Tony is he's different than any
other guys you ever play because he's
really suicide did you have you ever
thought about killing yourself no I
haven't actually I've been very lucky I
haven't really suffered from any mental
illness outside the norm of grief you
know you my mum died of lung cancer and
it was horrible
but III don't think I wake up
irrationally going I want to write about
that and that's luck you know it's it's
a it's some people get so I haven't had
that but you have rage issues
yes I think that during a nice bill in
San Francisco and your [ __ ] projector
in your outer world I know it's at least
okay so people doing things that are
annoying that is true they are annoying
they should know they don't do that in a
[ __ ] restaurant if their way and
that's that's the [ __ ] truth me
wanting to kill him I know he's
irrational so I don't so i control but
they still do what they're doing
yeah and and and I'm not yeah so my only
choice is to leave because I know I'm
not in charge of the world which annoys
me as well so I carry earplugs with me I
mean really yeah just in case right
oh because I know that I can't go up to
people and say you annoying me I was
offended one so out on a plane again
first-class be a little II bear this
woman walked down the aisle and she was
way too [ __ ] tired it annoyed me a
fight only because she was too tired it
was like she was celebrating being tired
I wanted to go open your eyes right no
not there tired yeah it's not to make a
show of it so everybody knows
yeah so yeah it's not a rage issue
because I don't I don't actually punch
anyone in the face or angry and shout in
public I you just matter you control
it's a bit it's controlled range I mean
it's passive-aggressive do you want a
tissue it's not a passive and Jane
becomes acutely aware of all of it well
I look at someone if someone's got a
voice like that in a restaurant there is
a voice right and there's lots of
categories the worst is annoying voice
right I'm talking bollocks and not
letting the person they're with talk so
that that gets that now I'm really
getting angry and I'm staring them and
Jane's going they don't know why you're
staring like they're gonna stare at me
obvious way to stare at me I'm talking
to you about I should quiet down a
little bit no no they just so ago where
they [ __ ] [ __ ] no I want people to
know what what being human is and
walking around in society why have it
walk around with their [ __ ] mouth
open shut your mouth it's crazy
ocean [ __ ] [ __ ] it's crazy mouth
breathers are as iron insane but you
know what the self-awareness I think
it's a much rarer quality than people
realize the level of self when you I
mean Jim you've met people with a very
low level of self-awareness almost it's
almost unbelievable unbelievable I know
I think they think they're in their
space and they can do with that not
knowing that they're permanent in their
space with noise with smells you know
that it's not their space it's all
joined or like you'll say hey you're
doing this right now and though what an
[ __ ] Ricky is I think over you're
doing you are you are doing this I know
about that what good it does anyone it
still is everyone's right to go in a
public place they're just [ __ ]
disgust alright he got kicked off the
plane cuz she was stuck between two
overweight people and she complained and
now she's fat she was kind of but she
was a little bit rude about it like she
wasn't she could have been nice very
petty what's that the the the plane
wasn't strike
[Laughter]
no space still wearing her space and
they were you know well she had the
middle seat between two fat people well
I think I think she's sort of got a
point she does but yeah she wasn't nice
about it she could have nicer because
she started yelling yet a salad people
yeah well you know that's a little bit
afraid that that's rude and that's not
our place to tell him how they lose
weight but it's a your kidneys are in my
face yes I can't breathe I can't breathe
this isn't for your help this is for my
health yeah it means you're right to get
fat right it's my right to have a full
seek to myself as well as I pie and
that's just scumbag Airlines that
[ __ ] you know I can see smaller I've
been to Irish I've been saying for a
decade they should have every single
seat in economy for should have like a
little thin thing that you can raise
well you both get exactly half the
armrest that would solve everybody's
problems should be anyway I thought I'd
would like a barrier a physical barrier
and you're right that if you can't get
into it then you've got to take a
different fly and you raise it and you
both have half the armrest that's it so
if you're 600 pounds if you're 120 yeah
there's like a little wall but that's
how you know if you need to buy two
seats or not yeah and you can put it
down if you want if you can't raise the
wall you need to buy two seats because
then the next wall has to be exactly
yeah yeah I'm all for the wall even
though first-class and British Airways
gotta be nicer than sitting in economy I
mean it's at least a certain amount of
space yes I mean it is amazing do you
know why I do I do it more to provision
to be left alone
you know I keep saying to people I don't
think it's my right to be in first class
just uh can afford it if if I said first
class is full and everyone sniffing but
economy's empty I'll go I'll go to
economy right there's no doubt about it
right I've I've asked for a smaller
trailer on a film before because the big
trailer they gave me was too near a
school so it's it's legally no
temptation
horton allowed people screaming kids
screaming when I'm trying to assure its
there a different trail I said where's a
tiny one down there I said I love that
one
so is it you wouldn't lost your mind the
hotel that I was the hotel that I was
just staying at last night in Cleveland
it's like this hotel that's in this mall
it's in a mall but it's a hotel as well
all right and the rooms open up into the
mall like they just open right up and
you're in this mall but they had allowed
a private event to go down in the bottom
floor cool and there's only like three
floors and it was a wedding and they
were there go ahead and shut down before
go this is good this is going from 5:00
to 11:00 p.m. and so I hope that that's
okay and I'm like yeah I'm sure to be
fine I went into my room
and I realized that I might as well just
tap out until after 11:00 p.m. beer
there's it's as if I'm at the wedding
it's blaring through every again it's
it's like it's really unfair I did a gig
at this venue I love the venue but
upstairs there was a gem session so it
was banging all way through and the next
night I said you've got to shut the gym
and they wouldn't so I never play that
venue again it's mad you just say you
shut down a wedding though well no I
called down I said there's noise what
yeah it's a wedding I went and and they
went wait it's only going to a midnight
hour yeah I'm going to bed now there and
I went okay I'll ask them to turn it
down
I went thank you did they they turned
the music down yeah I should yes it's
not my problem it's not my moral duty to
go Oh someone's getting married and it's
[ __ ]
it's [ __ ] the room that I've paid
$1,000 for right I let them off because
it's their wedding day that they if they
said I'll get people to check now if
they say they're waiting on okay I'll
get another hotel and you know fine
that's fine I'll go to another town you
know the [ __ ] you paying $1,000 I don't
I don't know i when I'm on soil cares
yeah they pay station line no do you not
I mean I hadn't said that why the
problem I mean if you go on first-class
be a to a thousand dollar room the last
thing you need is the peasants
celebrating
I can hear a little noise in my trail
you are when you're creating art you
think the world was I was we doing a
scene in extras in the graveyard there's
a scene in the graveyard where I live
that there's the dullard and I lie about
my my dead mom being Jewish and all this
sort of stuff oh so with so the location
master system we said and we've got to
be finished in the graveyard by midday
because there's a few a few neuron and I
went all day they won't bother us
[Laughter]
I was doing Vox pops once right for a
show and Levitt epoxy my first job doing
Vox box we want such pop ups and when
you go in there and say stupid things to
the general public like men on the
street so I'd ask them what's you know
stupid things like what would you if you
what's the best thing you can rob an old
lady of you know stupid questions and
they just answer see dignity yeah
and we're on a sort of like at this
place and someone came out of their own
house and a take and I went they were
coming out of their own house how would
you know
I mean I know you do this to everyone
but vos seems to be volunteering to be
the butt of joy I know you come back
with killers more he's a mean person
oh yeah he's um no when did it start
oh no it's not the odds but we like for
Mia you push Voss and eventually he will
heat you back so hard it's all worth it
like I'm just waiting to my rights as
Wow I'd do it to Robin insan my show
because when he comes back at me on a
slam I make a mistake I eat [ __ ]
kills me yeah Oh Robin in up I talked to
Robin inside and then it takes so much
and then he goes in a [ __ ] diatribe
about all of it and it just [ __ ]
kills me fighting back it's just this
great yeah oh my friends me him Bobby
growing up was it was play fighting
that's how you [ __ ] that's why we're
comedians because we sharpen our talent
when we're [ __ ] the owner you know
but you also know you can hit each other
as hard as you were that's the best part
I'm never worried about offending him
I'm certainly not worried about I know
that is that that is like when you have
to tread neg showers because someone
might take it wrong that's not funny at
all that's the worst trait there are no
sense of humor I'd rather be with
murderers if you take a joke I love my
wife cuz she's a con and she's so funny
we really come together one where we
have the same hero for the same con are
we here but last night I was at the
cellar decent you these new comics I
said some to this new calm or whatever
it is yeah and what's it doing someone
doing five and you haven't heard of them
under seven years you only be so good at
seven years to even 20
35 years Wow
35 some sheep will learn faster yeah
five albums anyhow nice ring still by
the way thank you that's just another
empty part of no no no slice show your
success first-class rich he likes to
show his wealth through physical means
good fingers square metals and stones go
with your pasty skin Ling is not
necessary just like like he's a wealthy
guy he's very successful he wants to
show the world I support it thank you
I said nice sneakers like little bling
Concord 11 zon very well on backwards if
someone's dressed in from an SNL Scott
is playing the role of David
all right so why'd you say the comments
you know a negative funny thing and he
goes wow what's that about well just say
stupid your Shelton I know it's almost
and I'm sick of comics going after other
comics bottom signaling and I've and
it's been on this Ray and you were
always great and it's just like it's
people kicking it when they're down and
they're basically saying to the public
look at me I'm not like that I know
aren't I [ __ ] brilliant that's what
virtual signal is I'm I'm so good I pick
on them I knew shy of people [ __ ]
judgment or [ __ ] honestly I can't
stand it there's way too much of it
about well it's only killing their First
Amendment right to but every time you go
after a [ __ ] karmic guess at karmic
you only hurt your [ __ ] self calm
down dude he's funnier than you yeah
these [ __ ] social warriors out there
you know shut up not so sure that social
worry my neighborhood they were warriors
national address I'm not going to use
all the words same thing picking said
that one I'm not gonna write all the
words